science fiction novels are often filled
with advanced technology and futuristic
societies alien worlds and alien races
much of the time in science fiction
humans have conquered the Stars and
found their own place among the cosmos
good science fiction is meant to
challenge the reader to think in new
ways and to challenge the reader to
consider things that they otherwise
might not have considered that being
said is there a place in science fiction
for mysticism
there are several authors who have added
elements of mysticism into their work in
this video we focus on how some elements
of mysticism are portrayed and
deconstructed in the classic science
fiction work dune by Frank Herbert and
in Dan Simmons 1984 series the Hyperion
cantos this video will contain some
pretty significant spoilers for both
series
[Music]
mysticism is somewhat of a difficult
word to define essentially mysticism is
the idea that through contemplation or
by surrendering to some esoteric unknown
that one can find spiritual apprehension
and understanding of arcane forces that
perhaps drive the universe in fantasy
books mysticism is more easily portrayed
but science fiction unlike fantasy does
not have the option to rely on magical
elements within the narrative to portray
forms of mysticism instead science
fiction authors who choose to include
some form of spirituality in their work
have to go about it from a different
angle which ultimately leads to them
explaining away much of the mysticism
the Hyperion cantos by Dan Simmons talks
of the void which binds an unseen
incorporeal realm of existence which
pervades the entire universe the void
which bind is also referred to by a more
technical name in the series blank space
because of its nature the void which
binds is not very well understood by the
vast majority but it is the domain that
connects all of reality binding the
universe together it was thought that
all consciousness flowed from the void
which binds one who mastered the void
which binds did this through empathy and
compassion for the void was also a realm
of emotion a master of the void could
bind their own being to the
consciousness of any other living
creature and since the void existed
beyond time they could even interact
with those who had died experiencing
their thoughts and memories and finally
one who had mastered the void was also
able to physically travel through time
the Hyperion cantos takes some elements
of real world religions and mythology to
expand upon the concept of the void
which binds as well keep in mind that
these books are works of fiction and
don't necessarily reflect the truth of
the real world the book suggests that
the biblical figure Jesus was perhaps
not the Son of God but in fact the first
human who was able to travel through the
void which binds and realizing that the
secret to unlocking the portal lied
within his DNA he gave of his literal
blood and body his DNA during the Last
Supper in order to allow his disciples
to connect with
Boyd but his disciples have been driven
to near madness their attempt to reduce
the intangible into words ultimately
failed
they became dogmatic and the portal
closed yet again mysticism in dune is
betrayed differently from the Hyperion
cantos the Freeman religion is based on
a mix of Buddhist and Islamic beliefs
and the Freeman have a large variety of
superstitious traditions much of their
religious views were implanted by the
Binney Jesuit sisterhood long ago under
their mission ara protect IVA a protocol
of religious engineering the giant worms
of the desert on the planet Arrakis who
the Fremen called shia elude were
directly tied into frim and mysticism
when a young sand worm was drowned it
produced the deadly substance in which
the Freeman called the water of life
only a Reverend Mother Messiah Deena had
the power to change the substance
converting it the Freeman would drink of
the water of life after it was converted
and experience its narcotic properties
in some it would unlock dormant press
Santa site the concept of press science
like the concept of the void which binds
in the Hyperion cantos at first seems
more mystical than it is presence in
dune is actually based on the ability to
understand and recognize patterns the
genetic information was always there
simply needing to be unlocked this is
how later the second the god emperor of
dune describes his golden path in a
conversation with the goal of duncan
idaho I have set up a pattern in it a
pattern of patterns so you say
information is frozen in patterns Duncan
we can use one pattern to solve another
flow patterns are the hardest to
recognize and understand since
individuals had the potential to
recognize patterns to varying degrees
some had greater prescient abilities
than others none in the original saga
were ever as powerful as the god-emperor
the spice could unlock prescient in some
mini Jesuit due to the greatly honed
abilities relating to powers of
perception
this was also how the guild navigator
acquired prescence it is related to
calculation essentially the god
emperor's goal was to prevent future
prescient
entities from seeing humans impressing
us he said this to Duncan and ciona
I give you a new kind of time without
parallels it will always diverge
there will be no concurrent points on
its curves I give you the golden path
that is my gift never again will you
have the kinds of concurrence that you
once had
if humanity's patterns could no longer
be recognized
then pressings cannot be used against
them it is for perhaps this reason that
those who are prescient have a difficult
time seeing each other in their
prescient sight since one who is
prescient can foresee and shape their
own path to their liking they could not
be tracked in the same way as a non
prescient entity so that was just a
brief look into how both of these series
portray mysticism Herbert and Simmons
both present concepts which on the
surface seem magical but as details are
gradually given we receive a better
understanding and realize that what they
are describing is in fact not
supernatural but completely tied to the
natural world
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure you like and subscribe for more
ideas of Ice and Fire
and to my dune fans out there I assure
you that chapterhouse dune Episode seven
of my ultimate guide to dune is coming
soon
I've been having art commissioned
because there's actually not a lot of
fan art that I could use that's been
done for those later books so I've been
actually getting art commissioned for
the first time with chapter house dude
the artists have been producing some
incredible work but it is a little on
the expensive side so if you want to
support this channel click the patreon
link in the description I hope to make
ultimate guide to do an episode 7 the
best episode yet